So the specific objectives
of this lesson are for
us to dive deeper into the Harris
corner detector algorithm.
Now, we have already
looked at it briefly.
Here we are going to talk about
the various steps that go into making
the Harris corner detector algorithm,
and
also look at a variety of differences
and variants on the basic algorithm,
that'll help us understand how
we can do feature detection.
In addition, I will also describe
the more widely used SIFT algorithm,
which is actually pretty much used on
most softwares that actually do any kind
of feature deduction and matching.
Just to recall, our goal is to
start off with two images and
our interest is to find features
in these images, like these.
And then also, find features in
another image in an image pair.
And then match them, saying this
is the same feature as that one.
So finding the similar features
across two images is our goal.
And to do this, we have been spending
a lot of time, actually from
the earliest lectures, trying to
learn how we can get inside and
find repeatable features
that actually can be
detected more reliably across images,
even though the images might be changed.
In this case, the change is subtle.
Just a pan from one view to the other.